tu
me suis tout le monde est fait d'
histoires et toutes ces histoires
sont ici mais la plus grande histoire commence
le jour du jour où les esprits
passent entre les murs regardent leurs deux meilleurs
amis amoureux d'une fille étrange ai-
je mentionné  J'ai étudié l'escrime vous deux
agissez comme cool avec moi pour vous vous êtes choisi
une tarte vous êtes que diriez-vous d'un
petit pari alors est-ce que maria épousera
très bien Joaquin le pari est réglé par moi-
même ou non c'est tellement beau Je ne suis peut-être pas
le héros de la ville  Maria mais je jure de tout
mon cœur et je n'arrêterai jamais de
bien aimer je perdrais le moyen de résoudre ce problème
pour moi vieil ami
bienvenue au pays des souvenirs
j'espère juste que
si vous accomplissez ces tâches vous
reverrez le vrai
ma dame s'il vous plaît  aidez-moi à retrouver l'
amour de ma vie
, pensiez-vous que ça allait être si facile que
je ne pouvais pas gérer